If you are familiar with knitting slip
stitch patterns on the single bed,
multi-colored slip is
the next logical step.
While knitting in slip selected needles
do not knit and the working yarn travels
under the needles creating floats
on the purl side of the knitting.
By changing colors every two rows,
a design is created on the knit side
of the knitting, allowing
multiple colors across the row.
The slip stitches are carried across
the alternating colors,
creating interesting graphic elements.
The best way to understand multicolored
slip is to knit it in two contrasting
colors and examine the stitches
that are slipping.
You don't need a color changer
to knit 2-color slip.
You could manually change the yarn every
two rows to get an idea of how this works.